you know the truth is you can't really
know for sure unless you were in a sleep
lab when when you come in for a sleep
study or polysomnogram we look at a
number of different parameters we look
at your EEG so I can tell whether you're
asleep what stage of sleep you're in the
positions of sleep and a number of
different parameters that a tracker
simply couldn't measure some of these
fitness trackers measure your sleep the
problem with those is some there are
certain studies that showed some
underestimate your sleep some
overestimate your sleep depending on
it's tracking measures so I'd be careful
about relying too much on fitness
trackers because if you sit still if you
lay completely still it assumes that
you're asleep but you may not be I would
say go by go by how you're reacting
during the day and those different
things that we talked about whether it's
the drowsiness the yawning the falling
asleep early have refreshed you feel in
the morning hitting the snooze button
those are those are great indicators